nehmen sie uns noch einmal ein bisschen
mit in die ukraine wir wissen die ersten
fluggesellschaften haben ihre flüge
gestrichen wir hören dass die
us-botschaft geheime dokumente verbrennt
festplatten zerstört das erinnert ja so
ein bisschen an afghanistan kann man
sagen oder ja so die lage ist schon
dramatisch wie gesagt wir sind froh dass
keine panik ausbricht aber
das was oder worauf wir uns jetzt heute
gefasst sein müssen ist das schlimmste
szenario und das bedeutet eben das
vielleicht die hauptstadt schon in den
nächsten tagen bombardiert werden kann
mit luftwaffe und da ist natürlich
russland überlegen und deswegen komme
ich wieder zurück zu dem punkt dass was
ihr sein das wahrscheinlichste szenario
von dem sie ausgewogen und also sind die
szenarien und jedes von ihnen scheint
plausibel zu sein ob das nur in der ost
ukraine oder im süden eine seeblockade
oder auch jetzt vom form von morden ihm
das auch die hauptstadt bedroht ist sind
keine 200 kilometer entfernt wurden
grenze jetzt haben wir massive drucken
auch in belarus auch dann ist die gefahr
gestiegen und zwar massiv das heißt wir
wollen vorbereitet sein auf jedes
mögliche szenario und wir wollen aber
auch
um auch die möglichkeiten zur zu haben
was können wir in gegensätzen diese
dieser übermacht an an an der luftwaffe
oder was die schiffe betrifft das sind
wir wirklich eine leichte beute für vier
booten und es hier hinein keine chance
gegen die russische armee richtig haben
also unsere entschlossenheit ist auch
glaube ich ein wichtiger punkt der herr
putin aber ich war dort die nächste tor
und dann gesehen wie sich die menschen
vorbereitet haben mit holz gewähren und
und ja ganz ganz alten gewähren wenn man
dann die hoch technologisierten
russische armee sieht muss man ja sagen
da hat die ukraine daher ist auf unsere
bitte nach wie vor und an die deutsche
politik dass man über denkt dass man
diese blockadehaltung beiseite schiebt
und zur erkenntnis konnte man kann
natürlich nicht diese
übermacht von von russland jetzt mit
einem schlag etwas
etwas entgegensetzen was wirklich was
wir machen aber ich habe die situation
helfen der manic also russland droht
damit oder es gibt szenarien dass am
mittwoch ein angriff kommen was könnte
ihre ukraine dann aus ihrer sicht jetzt
helfen also bei dem besuch von ja wir
werden zum beispiel die über zwei und
2000 panzer die die russen haben und die
sie auch einsetzen könnten jetzt bei der
bodenoffensive
das heißt sollte oder hätte die
ukrainische armee jetzt aus deutschland
diese unterstützung bekommen an anti
panzer raketen dann genau 12.000 stück
ja würden dann vielleicht ausreichen um
auch diese offensive fordern zum stocken
zu bringen fordern sie dass das jetzt
noch passieren sondern auf jeden fall
das ist unsere bitte die die liegt auf
dem tisch diese bitte erneut wir
tagtäglich jetzt auch mit briten waren
im moment haben wir noch keine antwort
bekommen dass er sehr schade weil wir
sehen dieser krieg ist ist also wie wir
spüren dann auch dieses krieges und wir
spüren den rust von von diesen panzer
die an unsere grenzen rollen aus allen
ecken der russlands und dass das macht
keinen spaß hätten keine antwort auf
diese
verzweifelten der ukraine muss man ja
sagen das land umzingelt von allen
seiten und deutschland antwortet nicht
und sagt nein waffen verteidigung gibt
es nicht ich weiß nicht ob deutschland
nicht antwortet ich habe mit herrn wenig
bei verschiedenen gelegenheiten darüber
gesprochen und er weiß auch was die
antwort an dieser stelle ist insofern
über fehlende antworten übrigens schon
zu der zeit der bundeskanzlerin von frau
merkel kann sich die ukraine glaube ich
nicht beklagen es ist die überzeugung
der bundesregierung der alten wie der
neuen gewesen dass eine wirksame
abschreckung russlands nicht gelingt auf
den militärischen gebiet sondern diese
abschreckung nur gelingt die man
russland vorführt was für einen
politischen und militärischen preis
dieses haben wird oder was ist denn das
herr reicht herr trittin was ist wenn
der angriff
danach sei sie diesen preis und ich
glaube das wird wohl kalkuliert an
dieser stelle sein ich bin nach wie vor
der auffassung dass dies der wirksamere
und richtige antwort darauf ist und
nicht der versucht machen ein absolutes
militärisches ungleichgewicht symbolisch
ein stück zu verschieben also ich sehe
das anders
so symbolisch ist das nicht wie gesagt
12.000 panzer 12.000 anti panzer die
haben sie eine bis mittwoch da also wir
haben seit monaten darum gebeten und
erledigen die antwort blieb aus und
jetzt haben wir über 1000 flugzeuge also
luftwaffe in russlands das heißt da
hätten 1000
luftabwehrraketen vielleicht hätten
gereicht um auch diese gefahr vielleicht
gewisser weise zu wahren wir haben vor
schon vor vielen jahren nachdem russland
die krim besetzt hatte und der
ostukraine hat sich eingemischt hatte
heiße diskussion mit unseren kollegen im
us-senat gehabt republikanern wie
demokraten die geschlossen der meinung
waren man muss den preis für putin
hochtreiben ich formuliert etwas salopp
und eben auch die europa eine
militärisch helfen wir haben dann immer
gesagt wir wollen den konflikt nicht
militärisch eskalieren weil am ende des
tages hat russland die dominanz da kann
russland kann immer mehr militärisch tun
in der region als die ukraine auch mit
noch so guter unterstützung ich habe
diese position immer mitgetragen aber
das bild hat sich eben letztes jahr
komplett verändert denn putin hat ja
einseitig die situation in der region
militärisch eskaliert und zurzeit
vermutlich 130 140 tausend russische
soldaten in russland und belarus an der
ukrainischen grenze das war eben nicht
das szenario und das wollten wir ja
genau vermeiden mit unserem wollten ja
keinen vorwurf vorwand liefern dafür
rosa zulieferer sind deswegen bin ich
jetzt der meinung defensivwaffen für die
ukraine jeden wunsch der ukraine
sorgfältig prüft also positionen sagen
sie jetzt sind waffen okay nein ich habe
es auch ohne vorher gebracht und ich
möchte den zuständigen bundesminister
zitieren der im mai oder juni letzten
jahres noch als wahlkämpfer am in der
ukraine war und an der frontlinie ein
interview gegeben hat dass ich ganz klar
so verstehe dass er gesagt hat den
wunsch nach defensivwaffen könne man den
ukrainern ja nicht verwehren ich würde
sagen die deutsche bundesregierung
sollte wie wir das in nordiran bei den
pacemaker auch getan haben über ihren
schatten springen es gibt keine
rechtliche es gibt keinen rechtlichen
grund dass deutschland das nicht könnte
wenn das bundeskabinett das beschließen
wollte könnte das bundeskabinett auch
einzelne export wünsche von
rüstungsgütern genehmigen ich fand das
total schade dass scholz in washington
den eindruck erweckt hat das sei in
deutschland gebe es so hohe rechtliche
hürden das ist nicht der fall wir haben
eben gerade kein gesetz im deutschen
bundestag sondern die bundesregierung
hat die flexibilität vor dem hintergrund
ihrer verantwortung gegenüber den
partnern zu entscheiden was sie tut und
ob sie etwas macht ich bin auch dagegen
waffen zu liefern die die russen real
als bedrohung ihres eigenen territoriums
verstehen also leopard panzers kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen aber wie kann ich
hab jetzt helfen er hat das ist ja eine
berechtigte frage jetzt unabhängig davon
was man vorher nicht wollte oder wollte
was kann man jetzt tun damit am mittwoch
plant die mir putin nicht die ukraine
angreift bzw dass die ukraine sich
verteidigen also ich würde zunächst
einmal sagen dass die bundesregierung
rasch auf den wunsch ist es da nicht
antworten sollte die alte volksarmee
panzerhaubitzen liefern wollen an die
ukraine das geht möglicherweise recht
schnell und die sind auch vielleicht
nicht so kompliziert dass also die
panzerhaubitzen sofort an die front
nicht an die front sondern in der
ukraine an die stellen positionieren wo
man einen möglichen angriff mit diesen
waffen abwehren kann das sind keine
waffen mit dem man das territorium
russlands bedroht sondern das sind
waffen mit dem man im zweifel verhindern
kann dass die russischen streitkräfte
wie ein messer durch die butter auf gf
marschieren sondern dass sie schon
wissen dass sie ein hohes militärisches
risiko gehen herr lahm software für mich
nur ein teil der antwort sie sind ich
sage mal frühere diplomat weil sie jetzt
politiker sind sie kennen sich aus in
dem geschäft kann scholz sagen am
mittwoch oder am dienstag bei pleiten
wie putin wenn nichts passiert dann
schicke ich panzerhaubitzen oder lasst
die panzerhaubitzen durch aus estland
beeindruckt dass wladimir putin ein das
sind 9
die sind über 50 jahre alt die stammen
aus den beständen der ddr die ändern
nichts und das ist ein punkt wo man
einfach nicht aber eines ganz klar sein
muss ich habe das am anfang gesagt was
hier als szenario droht also eine große
in version ist nicht im nationalen
interesse der russischen föderation
es ist das ende der beziehung zu europa
das muss man sagen das muss stolz sagen
joe biden hat bedeutet das das ende der
beziehung das für unsere botschaften
vielleicht will putin auch ja dieses
ende ja wir wissen dass nicht er hat
große angst
euro-bereich jetzt ist bedeutet dass wir
die wirtschaftsbeziehungen auf das
absolute minimum maß zurückfahren das
betätigungsverbot erlassen werden dass
es schwieriger werden wird für russische
banken sich zu refinanzieren ist wird
ende freunde so harten preisgeben
wirtschaftlich wie wir das in der
vergangenheit noch nie gemacht aber das
sage ich ja es gibt ein herr rolf
einmahl wir hören das immer aber es ist
ja auch wahr es ist ja auch war der
punkt ist doch der wenn wir haben keine
chance und das ganz klar zu sagen den
ukrainischen streitkräfte so viele
waffen zu liefern dass wir an der stelle
die strategische
kalkulation im kreml ändern können
vollkommen ausgeschlossen sie glauben
doch nicht im ernst dass wladimir putin
angst vor neuen trans haubitzen aus der
ddr habe aber heute wird wo sind ja aber
es geht nicht um haubitz dann ist es nur
ein 1 1 1 1 1 test ja ein lackmustest
die deutsche politik ja ich gehe ja
nicht nur diese 19 oder neue metropole
aber ihr chef der außenminister hat ja
als annalena baerbock in kiew und klar
gesagt hat nein es wird aus deutschland
keine legalen waffen also keine
tödlichen das haben daneben das hatte
ich gesagt habe gesagt okay das
feiervolk hatte ist gesagt herr kollege
hat dann gesagt sehr diplomatisch sehen
und hat gesagt das stimmt aber ist es
nicht auch die erlöse gar nicht was ich
habe doch gar nicht sagt was ihr kollege
sagt sie in der pressekonferenz kann man
ja nachher er hat gesagt wenn wir waffen
brauchen wissen wir auch wo wir her
bekommen können und ich glaube dass
wichtig zu wissen wir haben an den
deutschlandweit
2014 als bundeskanzlerin merkel als die
cdu-regierten damit 2014 im angesicht
einer einseitigen eskalation von mutina
das war ja die krim und der don bosco
einseitige eskalation da hat die damals
cdu geführte bundesregierung gesagt wir
machen keine waffen sondern wir machen
sanktionen und wir setzen russland unter
druck und wir haben jetzt eine situation
wo die strategischen kalkulation im
kreml nicht durch ein paar euro bezahlt
werden sondern nur durch die einzuladen
hat während in den vergangenen jahren
schwere fälle laporte ich erinnere mich
ich war reporter in der ukraine und
immer wieder habe ich gehört dass es
jetzt dann ist doch nicht herunter was
nicht
es hat nicht geklappt hat gesehen dass
uns hinten ist doch nicht weiß ist war
die situation schlimmer geworden
der nachricht von der schlinge russlands
um den hals der ukraine aber ist schon
die kinder sie kennen geben der ukraine
gut aus und sie wissen genau dass diese
dauernden spekulationen gegeben hat
mario pohl wird angenommen dass ihr das
neue russische projekt alte fürst banken
wurde wieder ausgegraben katharina die
zweite das odessa eingenommen wird es
gab diese ganzen szenarien die sind alle
nicht gekommen und wir wissen nicht ob
da nicht diese sanktions kalkulation im
kreml dem ganzen zu grunde wenig wie ist
ihr eindruck hat dass irgendetwas
gebracht der eindruck den die ukraine
heute haben ist dass wir von den
deutschen auch im stich gelassen werden
weil
man kann viele ausreden finden sollte
aber aber es geht darum dass die ukraine
jetzt nicht das gefühl haben dass sie
sich auf die deutschen in dieser
schwierigen lage verlassen aber darum
gehen könnte schon sagen dass wir mehr
tun als die allermeisten anderen auf der
welt das geht nicht darum situation
ist die wahrheit
nicht interessiert es interessiert ihn
nicht dass deutschland der größte
investor in der ukrainer ist es
interessiert ihn auch nicht das stimmt
das ist eine deutsche bundeskanzlerin
war die nicht meiner partei angehört die
dazu beigetragen hat dass weiterhin gas
aus russland durch die ukraine durch
geleitet worden ist sondern sie
versuchen an der frage von 16 oder neun
museumsreifen panzerhaubitzen die
deutsche zuverlässigkeit in frage zu
stellen und ich finde das hat dann auch
mal so erreicht man dann auch so eine
grenze wo man sagen muss ja da haben wir
einen dissenz ich drücke das jetzt mal
setzt sich sehr diplomatisch
ich widerspreche hennig ich widerspreche
ihrer behauptung dass die alte
bundesregierung oder die jetzige
bundesregierung die ukraine im stich
gelassen habe ich nicht nicht gejuckt
widerrechtliches auch dem wieder richten
auch das schaffen sie selber was sie
selber vergangenen donnerstag hier mit
der bundesregierung sie waren bei der
entwicklungsministerin sie waren beim
wirtschaftsminister sie haben mit den
fraktionen gesprochen hat dann
offensichtlich erwarten sie von etwas
und sie haben ist auch als zusagen
bekommen ich war dabei wir haben gar
nichts bekommen also herr trittin achte
ihre frage 1,8 milliarden euro
dass sie jetzt in den vordergrund
stellen und das was die ukraine in den
letzten acht jahren bekommen haben wir
sind dankbar dafür wir schätzen dass
aber alleine das dass die dass
deutschland jetzt die neuesten zwei
vorangetrieben hat dazu geführt dass das
wir innerhalb eines jahres zwei
milliarden us dollar an gebühren
verloren und das wird auch weiterhin
gehen und wenn ihn drei wegen aus den
zeiten wenn in drei jahren der transit
zum erliegen kommt wie es aussieht oder
sogar früher dann heißt das dass wir
jedes jahr nur noch 34 jahren woher
sollen hierbei ist ein super sich vor
dem man das ist eigentlich vom markt
fernhalten deswegen weiter das lilien
ich hätte ihnen auch so drückt nicht
widersprechen